Prof: Today's case,
SELCO SEWA,
is a wonderful transition to
Collier's Bottom Billion
and a--
I want to start with some
frameworks and I'm going to do
these briefly.
I'll post them this evening so
you can look back at them.
I want to introduce--these are
very standard MBA-ish,
shorthand frameworks for
thinking about cases.
You heard, I think most of
this, but I should rub it in a
bit.
One is called SWOT,
and this one has really no
analytical content to it,
it's just a way of organizing
your thoughts on a topic,
strengths, weaknesses,
opportunities,
threat.
In the temporal dimension
typically the strengths and
weaknesses are things which are
immediately present in your
situation,
and the opportunities and
threats are things you might
have happen to you or might
cause to occur.
A lot of back of the envelope
thinking about business cases is
organized in this shorthand.
You might make yourself a grid
like,
this and let the column heading
be SWOT,
and then let the row headings
be whatever you choose,
but one candidate is the Porter
forces,
which we've seen before.
How fierce is the direct
competition in your business
from other people doing more or
less exactly what you do and
trying to do it better than you?
What's the threat that others
not now doing it will enter the
business and increase
competition?
How likely is it that people
will find substitutes for your
whole industry,
that your industry will be
undermined by an adjacent
industry?
I could tell--I was able to
determine which letter it was.
Can you hold that up and tell
us what it's about?
Student:
>
crimes of sexual violence that
are inflicted upon civilians as
a result of the mineral
conflict,
such as copper and coltan,
which were frequently found in
our own devices such as iPods,
cell phones,
and cameras so just trying to
draw attention to the crisis.
Prof: Terrific.
It's certainly an eye-catching
accessory as you walk in.
The threat of substitution then
the power of your suppliers in
the SELCO case,
think about where you're buying
the basic components of these
generation and lighting systems.
If there's only a limited
number of sources,
or perhaps even just one
source, then they're in a
position to squeeze you on
price,
and that's an important
strategic consideration.
Buyers;
if buyers have a lot of
leverage, or as in the SELCO
case, not a lot of money,
then buyers become a central
point of strategic focus.
You could, if you wanted,
and I often do this,
you could combine SWOT across
the top with supply--
with Porter in the rows so that
if you take potential entrants,
threat of entry,
your strengths might be that
there's no money to be made in
this field,
so not many people are going to
want to do it,
or it might be that there are
huge switching costs so that
once people have bought your
equipment,
it is very difficult for them
to switch to other people's
equipment.
The weakness might be that
you're making money,
and that the Financial
Times just ran a large
article about how lucrative your
business is,
which is likely to attract the
attention of others.
Opportunities;
perhaps--how is barriers to
entry an opportunity?
Perhaps you can build pricing
advantages--
if you increase the scale of
your operation your unit costs
may get low enough that whenever
a new entrant comes,
you can crush him with low
prices.
Threat;
similarly, somebody else may
jump in and get the higher scale
of production much lower unit
costs and crush you.
You can walk all the way
through the twenty cells there,
but it--frameworks like this
are meant to be useful and when
they're useful they--
you use them,
and if there's a particular
cell here that doesn't make any
sense,
you just put an X through it
and go on.
Another concept that we've used
briefly and it gets to be
important in cases like SELCO is
vertical integration,
which I've drawn horizontally,
as almost everyone else does.
The rough idea here is that on
the left is the supply of raw
materials, and then making of
the product;
its assembly,
its distribution and sale all
the way out here.
The sale end is called the
forward part of integration,
so forward integration.
The raw materials and
intermediate products is called
backward integration,
and so defying all logic,
backward plus forward makes
vertical.
Don't ask me how that came
about.
Behind that process,
which we think of in very
physical terms,
is an intellectual and
managerial layer,
which starts not with raw
materials but with a business
plan,
and a product design,
and the assembly of a
management team,
and the creation of channels
for distributing the product.
Again, left to right,
and if you think about the
SELCO case--where's their main
focus on this arrow at SELCO?
What are they mostly paying
attention too?
Back left, you got to shout if
you don't have a microphone.
Student:  They--most of
their staff is focused on
distribution and sales within
India.
Prof: Okay,
absolutely, so the forward
integration of SELCO is its most
obviously unusual feature.
They're reaching into very
difficult markets to do the
sales and very awkward places to
do the service,
which has to go with the sales.
If you look now at--another way
of looking at the backward to
forward story,
it's--I reproduced what was
already there but then I've
added service out there.
It turns out that taking
responsibility for durable goods
that you sell,
there's not much long term
responsibility for toothbrushes
or toothpicks,
but there is a lot of service
responsibility for any form of
machinery,
especially when people are
going to organize their lives
around the machinery.
The classic insight on--classic
example on this is on McCormick
farm machinery in the 1800s.
The brilliant thing they did,
which none of their competitors
did,
was to manufacture only during
the winter season and use the
same people that were running
the manufacturing plant to be
servicing agents for the farmers
during the growing season so
that the advantage of buying
their stuff had everything to do
with service.
Now think about the laptop in
front of you,
take yours, is service an
issue?
Student:  Service,
like getting the service?
Prof: Well does it just
run forever and keep you happy?
Student:  It sometimes
has problems.
Prof: Okay and what do
you do?
Student:  I've sent it
off to the Mac Store.
Prof: Okay,
or you call them up and talk to
a so-called genius?
What a thought,
the "genius bar,"
and Mac's competitive advantage
is partly the elegance of the
equipment,
but a lot of it is that their
servicing is way better than
anybody else's.
Who's got a kind of computer
that service is hard to find
for?
You're all perfectly happy with
the support you get for your
computers?
Well that's wonderful;
improbable, but wonderful.
Okay, so you get with SELCO a
huge emphasis on the service end
of the business.
Okay now let's turn to the case
itself.
There's an A part and a B part,
the B part is really kind of
more like a teaching note than
an actual case.
The focus is on a certain rural
part of India and on sales to
people who are either in
business on a very small scale,
entrepreneurs of some kind,
or householders in an area that
is off the electric grid.
It's an interesting fact about
India that the electric grid is
highly problematic and
incomplete,
and the first mass development
of wind turbines was actually
begun in India by a textiles
manufacturer who got tired of
all the down time in his
reliance on grid electric power,
and started developing turbines
for his own use,
and then had the insight that
turbines were a more profitable
business then textiles for him
and switched altogether.
It's now headquartered in
Denmark and it's a huge company.
The alternatives to what these
guys are doing,
the ones mentioned in the case
are the grid,
Pico Hydro, and its very hard
for me to envision how you do
distributed generation with
water.
Well anybody got a thought
about this?
You live next to a running
stream and you build a little
water wheel--
it's got to be something a
little glitzier than that--
and wind turbine on a micro
scale.
Now what are the inherent
disadvantages of the distributed
generation strategy that SELCO
is engaged in?
If you were looking at it from
a business point of view what
would be factors that would
strike you as scary?
Yes.
Student:  Every time
they entered a new market they
had to convince the financial
institution to finance their
products to the market that they
were catering too,
so it was almost a barrier of
entry for them,
because the kind of people they
wanted to sell their products
too did not have the resources
and it was also a new concept
that they were introducing,
because financing was never
done with respect to energy
before in the country.
Prof: Okay so one
problem that is inherent in the
market segment they choose to
serve is that you've got a twin
door-to-door finance at the
micro level,
with door-to-door sale of the
generating equipment and the
lighting equipment,
so that's one difficulty.
Are there are any others?
Student:  Some days
there's no sun,
and then obviously a solar
system isn't going to work.
Prof: There are--and
there are some seasons in which
that happens repeatedly,
though in the part of India
they're doing it,
it's a pretty sunny place.
But--okay so that's a genuine
drawback, other thoughts?
Student:  Essentially
they're competing with the
government.
If the government chose to
expand the grid in the region
they're doing business,
that would put their business
plan at a decided disadvantage.
Prof: Okay there's a lot
said there, all in one elegant
sentence.
The biggest piece of it,
as I heard it,
was the threat that the grid
might expand into a given area.
Why would people,
once the grid came--switch from
SELCO's equipment to grid
equipment?
Student:  Probably cost,
it's more efficient to generate
electricity in a power plant
than in your own house.
Prof: Okay and is there
a general concept here?
Student:  Economies of
scale.
Prof: Economies of
scale, right?
The whole point of centralized
generation is huge economies of
scale so that if you--
if the grid is run reasonably
efficiently it will time after
time trump distributed
generation.
Why would we do this business?
What's the point?
Is this something that a
brilliant young reptile from The
Harvard Business School is going
to jump in to make his fortune?
Sasha what do you think?
Student:  No.
Prof: No, and why not?
Student:  I think there
are too many risks.
Prof: Too many risks,
and how big an upside is there?
Student:  I'm not sure
how you would quantify the
upside, but I'm not convinced
that it's huge enough to take
advantage of.
Prof: Okay.
Does anybody remember the
financing story for this?
What subsidies are required?
Let's watch a little bit of
film and get further along with
the actual story [video
17:00-23:00].
Okay the--if you had to
summarize what was just said
there in twenty words or less,
what would it be?
Sasha?
Student:  I think
ultimately they don't want to be
a bottom line company,
that their mission is not
purely financial.
Prof: Okay,
now help people who don't talk
bottom line counts to understand
what you just said.
Student:  Some of you
talk about a double or a triple
bottom line and then you have
people who are looking at social
returns and environmental
returns in addition to purely
financial returns.
Prof: Okay so--that's
terrific.
So heretofore we have talked as
if companies had one bottom line
and their net results were
correctly reflected in a profit
and loss statement.
What Sasha is suggesting is
that a firm like SELCO or a bank
like SEWA thinks about more than
one bottom line,
and they want to say that some
net losses in the financial
bottom line may be balanced and
overcompensated by gains in
environmental territory or in
social services.
This is capitalism hybridized
with non-profit service sector
institutions;
SELCO and SEWA are neither of
them, institutions which would
have been designed if you
thought about just one bottom
line.
The merit in them has to be
captured in social,
and to some extent,
environmental terms.
Now what's the market's message
to village India about the
availability of light and
electric current for purposes
like running small machinery or
heating water?
What's the market say?
Yes, this is the case where
there's exactly,
as economists say,
an equilibrium outcome.
What's--somebody got a hand up
over there, there we are.
Student:  I mean for the
darkness area there's simply
insufficient demand to justify
expanding the infrastructure
drastically across much of rural
India.
Prof: Okay all right,
so that's good.
Adam Smith distinguishes
between total demand and what he
called effective demand.
Total demand is how many people
put up their hands if you say
would you like electricity.
Effective demand is people who
would do that and back it up
with money, and effective demand
is very low.
Now not only is it low but
overcoming it with a grid
structure is inherently
difficult,
because while there are some
customers capable of paying
market rate for grid
electricity,
the vast majority of customers
in many of these regions are
below that income level and
could not afford any of the
above.
In addition to that,
their poverty is reinforced by
the absence of energy supplies.
If you don't have the energy
supplies to do small-scale
production,
or to illuminate a market
during evening hours,
or any of a hundred other such
things,
the low level of commerce is
kept low by the absence of
efficient energy supplies.
The justification for an
enterprise like this has
everything to do with finding a
way around the market
equilibrium at zero,
which prevails in some of these
places.
There's another feature in the
film clip.
What's the attitude toward
customers?
How does their attitude compare
with--well let's establish the
high end of the scale.
How does Yale do it providing a
choice of courses for you to
take?
Ridiculously well, right?
A third of Yale courses have
fewer than ten students;
think that over.
Imagine that you're brought a
cost accountant in here to look
at Yale College,
20% of my brothers and sisters
on the faculty would be looking
for a job,
and the enormous wealth of the
institution is what makes this
possible,
and it's a wonderful thing.
Now if you were--now go back
to, what's your least favorite
company that you deal with
routinely?
Most of you have an unfavorite
company?
I see a good nod right back in
the sixth row,
third seat in.
Student:  My least
favorite company ever is
Connecticut Limo.
Prof: Okay Connecticut
Limo, dare I ask?
Student:  They don't
give customers what they
promise, they're always late,
they're too expensive,
and they're mean.
Prof: Mean!
Okay, anybody else got an
unfavorite?
Over here--
Student:  McDonald's.
Prof: McDonald's;
what's your grudge against them?
Student:  I have many.
First how they market to
children, and how unhealthy
their food is in general.
Prof: Okay.
How many of you have eaten at
McDonald's sometime in the last
two weeks?
That's a really interesting
datum;
we're at about 3%.
I'll bet you are the lowest
McDonald's demographic in the
country.
Okay, but your objection to
McDonald's isn't--is it that
they don't offer a wide enough
range of customizations?
Student:  Partly.
Prof: Okay I mean if I
were them I would say to you,
come on what's the beef,
we offer you twenty sandwiches,
five breakfasts,
is it one flavor or more--
or two of ice cream?
Two of ice cream,
that's quite a lot.
Your beef is of another nature
isn't it?
Student:  That they
popularize unhealthy food.
Prof: Okay so you--if
you were king,
would you put them out of
business?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Okay.
I have a good friend and
prominent faculty colleague
named Kelly Brownell,
is Kelly Brownell visible to
all of you, some of you?
Brownell is the leading
advocate of the fat tax.
He himself is a big guy
actually, but he wants to tax
restaurant fat so that there
would be an excise tax on the
Big Mac of three or four bucks
because it is just one huge
clump of cholesterol.
We're off topic here,
the least favorite--
my least favorites are several
airlines and providers of
internet service,
and providers of television
signal.
It's because they're rigid,
their business strategy
involves a rigid interface with
customers,
and the Delta shuttle between
here and Washington--
brutal, just brutal the way
they do it.
That--and there's a reason for
that.
It's not just because they're
bad people,
they're not even bad people,
it's because there are huge
economies in not listening to
the details of what people want.
Do you want a ticket on the
shuttle or do you not want a
ticket on the shuttle?
It will leave at 8:17,
full stop, end of conversation,
and it isn't even actually a
conversation,
it is an interplay with a
website, and the website is
often kludgey,
uninformative and so on.
But in a cost benefit ratio
from their point of view it
works really well.
When you look at SELCO,
the first--
my first impulse would be to
say, simplify,
don't customize,
and get one product that you
can generate at much lower cost
and stay with it.
Remember how,
in the dialogue in the film
clip, and in the case he talks
about one size fits all doesn't
work.
What he means is that people
who can barely afford this
equipment are inclined to take
it only if you match it very
well with their preferences.
Now is that--somebody defend
SELCO please.
They're highly defendable.
Student:  I mean I guess
this goes back to the bottom
line we talked about,
and whereas SELCO and SEWA,
it's not just a for profit
bottom line;
they really want to help
people, and that comes up a lot
in the case,
wherein they thought that what
the name of the manager of SELCO
is that he really wanted to help
these people.
Unless he tries to at least,
to some extent,
customize his products he won't
be able to help as many people
as he would like too.
Prof: Okay that's good,
hand the microphone on here.
Student:  It's also sort
of about growing the market,
because if you provide a
customized solution to,
say, a street vendor,
and that vendor is able to
light his storefront,
make more money,
and maybe in the future when
he's adding another side to his
storefront he'll come back to
you and buy the full package.
Prof: Okay,
so there is a sort of
multiplier effect when on the
commercial side of this you
customize it correctly.
Now the major issue in the
background here is--what's the
size of this market worldwide?
Ballpark?
Student:  One billion
about.
Prof: Somewhere around a
billion,
so there are a hell of a lot of
customers out there,
and if that's so,
scalability as it's called,
becomes a pressing question for
a firm like SELCO.
Scalability would mean that you
could drive your costs low
enough and develop your
distribution system strongly
enough that you can reach vastly
more.
They are--when the case is
written,
they're still well under 10,000
households,
and at well under 10,000
households this is an
experiment,
a noble experiment,
but merely that.
It is a demonstration project.
Now a background fact about
them which isn't in the case is
this: I had lunch today with a
Yale College alum who worked
last year for an India company
that manufactures equipment like
this,
GWP, and GWP assigned her the
task of finding a sales
relationship with SELCO,
so she spent a year working
with SELCO trying to sell them a
high quality,
but completely standardized
system that was designed to
achieve scale economies.
Her experience was entirely
frustrating, because SELCO
ultimately wasn't interested in
achieving scale.
They were interested in serving
the immediate customer base in
front of them.
Okay what does that mean?
I think it means that SELCO is
a service company and is
destined to remain a very small
one.
Now in the case there's--in the
B case there is some discussion
about their not for profit
financing.
Anybody remember the amount of
financing they have?
No reason you should $462,000,
which isn't a monumental sum
but it's a pretty hefty sum if
you're talking about a few
thousand customers.
The rhetoric in the B case is
no, no we're going to get to
300,000 customers and the unit
cost will be $1 and change per
customers of the subsidy will be
that small.
Well I actually don't think
they're going to get there.
I don't think it can be done
with this level of
customization.
Okay, so now the task is each
of you is a management
consultant,
and you're brought in by the
board of the funder for SELCO,
and you've got to figure out
how to take the baby out of the
bathwater,
get rid of the bathwater and
come up with something scalable.
How would you go about that?
Anybody got a thought?
Would we fire management or not?
Over--yes--
Student:  First I would
try to get them to stop being
dependent on one geographic
area.
It seems like they really
concentrated between Bangalore
and I think it was Ahmadabad,
and like clearly there are a
lot of poor regions in India,
and once they get out of
those--that specific region,
I'm pretty sure they will be
forced to look at it a bit
differently.
Prof: Okay so let me see
if I understood that.
You want them to move into
higher income groups?
Student:  No,
I want them to go to another
poor region.
Prof: Okay you want them
to go to another poor
neighborhood and do what?
Student:  Clearly by
seeing that there are--
like since there are so many
different cultures within India,
and so many different needs,
that they continue this model
of customization they will see
they will ultimately fail,
and they need to start moving
into something else.
Prof: Okay.
I'm going to pretend to be
another person--a person on the
board.
"Look, we've already
figured out these guys are
running straight into a dead
end.
I'm inpatient,
all you're going to do is
demonstrate failure again.
Find me a better solution."
Now anybody think they've got
one?
Yes, far back.
Student:  I just figure
out a couple of SELCO's
products,
a couple of their best products
that numerically meet the needs
of the most number of people,
and then I would expand by
pushing those products and of
course in the process you would
lose out on customization and
individual solutions,
but if your goal is to provide
illumination to the maximum
number of people just kind of
focus on what you're good at and
skip that--
Prof: Focus on a few
products, sounds like a good
idea.
Now what about people who
are--remember there's talk in
the case about a pyramid.
There's even a picture of a
pyramid and we're talking about
serving people near the bottom
of the pyramid economically.
Is there a way that you might
think about serving people at
the bottom of pyramid by also
serving people a layer or two
above them in the pyramid?
Yes.
Student:  If you can
charge the people a little bit
higher up the pyramid more than
the systems, they can subsidize
the people below.
Prof: Okay,
so if you can take a--
you probably have to have the
product differentiated a little
bit to produce a higher margin
product which is very similar to
your straight product,
and build a distribution
channel in--
so that the same distributors
can cover the higher margin
product and also the low margin
product for the people at the
bottom of the pyramid,
and achieve some scale
economies so that you begin to
make the pump run on its own.
The video clip we just watched,
they talk about how when they
let distributors do what they
wanted,
the distributors ended up
drifting into higher income
strata,
and that's not very surprising
because the margins can be much
higher.
In the bottom channel,
unless you get the thing very
standardized,
the margins have to be negative
because people just can't afford
it,
so high customization at the
very bottom looks like a highly
problematic strategy,
inspiring as it may be.
Is there--are there other lines
of production unrelated to
electricity that strike you as
interestingly analogous to this?
For example,
let's say the nub of this idea
is distributed production.
Instead of centralized grid
production we're doing
distributed electric production
of electricity,
just as we have distributed
computing on all these laptops.
Are there other highly
distributed strategies that
might be of service in bottom
billion countries?
Okay, talk--say more--
Student:  You could
distribute mobile phones instead
of building a land line.
Prof: Okay has anybody
thought of that yet?
Student:  I'm sure, yeah.
Prof: Big time, right?
I mean the story here is land
lines become--completely
saturate the market and then
cell phones are a layer on top
of that.
In all the countries we'll be
talking about with
The Bottom
Billion, cell phones just
leap over land lines,
right, and are technologically
superior to land lines from
almost every point of in a very
low income setting.
That's a good suggestion.
Any others occur to anyone?
Jennifer?
Student:  Water
purification.
Prof: Okay water
purification and the technology
there is--how do you do it?
Student:  Well instead
of running pipes to transport
clean water to remote places you
could just build their own
filters or dig their own wells.
Prof: Okay you could
build your own filters,
dig your own wells might or
might not work,
depending on the water tables
depth and quality,
but yes it's a very good point
and right at the end of the
semester we'll see a case in
Bolivia--
Cochabamba, Bolivia where we
try to fix a water supply system
using straight capitalist
technique and get into a lot of
trouble.
We get into a lot of trouble
for the--
basically because the pricing
model for the capitalist to make
money leads to too high a price
for people who are right at the
bottom of Bolivia's pyramid,
which is not very different
from India's pyramid,
except it's got a lot less
growth in it.
That's--anybody else got one?
Student:  Fighting
malaria,
for example,
you could focus on like big
projects who alter the
landscape,
like draining swamps versus
just giving people,
giving mosquito nets in their
own homes.
Prof: Okay,
and the Gates' agree with you,
and are throwing billions at
them.
In general, there's this whole
family of models for multiple
bottom line businesses,
and some not so multiple bottom
line,
some straight out for profit
businesses.
Where having decentralized
production as in SELCO's
equipment, is a terrifically
valuable asset.
Now for Monday the main metric
that is used in the world for
progress, and what defines the
bottom billion as bottom
billion, is GDP per capita.
In my part of Monday's class,
which I'm about to record,
I'm going to pick at--I'm going
to start with the proposition
maximize GDP per capita and make
the country better.
Paul Collier more or less
advocates that in The Bottom
Billion.
I'm sympathetic to that view
but I'll set up some critical
screens to pass it through and
explain those,
and you'll see that video at
the beginning of class on Monday
and then after my little video
there is a Ted talk by Paul
Collier explaining what he
thinks his book has to offer.